[Music]
there's no time
[Music]
the time is thirteen o'clock
[Music]
what yeah here we are at saturday
[ __ ] sleepy don't be so enthusiastic
well less than a minute into the [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'm getting over all this sickness
getting over the sickness i was feeling
pretty good today my nose isn't [ __ ]
me like it was
tomorrow i'll probably feel real good
but um i don't know i just i felt good
up until about an hour ago and all of a
sudden i'm getting [ __ ] sleepy
but i got i got booze here you didn't
you didn't take your old man
no i didn't i'm gonna drink my way out
of this [ __ ]
that seems like a capital idea yes it
does
damn this topic sounds in here a minute
ago yeah
yeah a little pooky came in she was
trying to get in the closet i think she
thinks that the closet leads to outside
yeah or another house or another house
she's like maybe there's another house
on the other side of this it's more
interesting than
this she thought the dishwasher went to
another house remember that
beijing good too you open it up she's
like where's that going
wow it's like kidding narnia yeah
actually beijing got really mad at me
one time because i wouldn't let her
right well who's that finally look i
finally you got one now
i finally got a notification yeah oh my
god
[ __ ] yeah beijing got mad at me once
because i wouldn't let her get into the
dishwasher
she was very upset because i had i was
loading it or unloading it and she was
like trying to jump in and i'm like hey
can you not she's
i want to go into the other dimension
put my hat on
fingers crossed for no dropouts we've
actually
um we haven't had any problems since
last saturday
like we've streamed a lot since then and
seems fine so we'll see
how it goes i mean don't jinx it some
kind of that was some kind of
maintenance i think
yeah i think that might have been
something to do with our
wi-fi i think they maybe were working on
it in our area or something like
that but um today's show
will be about carl jung and uh yeah cool
you don't want to do this show for a
while yeah
carl young talked a lot about uh
paranormal and kind of like psychic
stuff
all right and he he wasn't um
a quack he had some he had some pretty
good theories and it kind of matches up
with what i saw in mad mountain
poltergeist
and he talks about things like poultry
guys phenomenal he he'd seen it
well yeah and he said pretty much the
same thing about it that you said that
he thought that it was an
exteriorization i think he even used
that exact word
um of people's mental turmoil
he tried to show it to freud freud
knocking and stuff freud didn't want to
accept it
yeah evidently we'll get into that a
little bit too because there's kind of
um
i don't know i just carl young is like
such a fascinating
person because it seems like like i said
you know he's mainly you know the
founder of i guess
analytical psychiatry analytical
psychology whatever
um you know in the whole thing with him
and freud like there
a lot of their ideas were similar but
they had like some pretty fundamental
differences as well
but i feel like carl young later on kind
of went off in a more
like mystical direction a little bit but
there was still some basis in i don't
know he was just like a fascinating
combination
of scientific rationality and like
mysticism well he believed in the
unconscious
and and the unconscious had a lot of
paranormal and mystical kind of
qualities to it he had he he made this
book while he was alive it never it
didn't get published in 2009 i think
until 2009 2009 it's called the red book
and it was just some it was just some
kind of legendary
you know mystical book it was kind of
like an ayahuasca trip or something he
was
drawn it had all these drawings and
stuff he worked on it for a long time
like 16 years i think he was like
adding [ __ ] in there yeah and evidently
he said that uh
that the book was kind of dangerous that
if you read it got into it too much it
would
it would start apparently it would cause
paranormal phenomena
that's what he said but you can get it
now
yeah they finally did publish it in 2008
well as i said i was just telling you
earlier that
i mean obviously people knew that the
red book existed like before then
because
you know carl jung died in the 60s and
like he'd been working on it prior to
that
but it had kind of been around he just
he'd been working on it off and on it
was
he never really um specified whether he
wanted the [ __ ] published or not um
you know to his relatives when he died
he did leave a lot of unpublished stuff
but he usually would say hey you know i
want this publisher
that not published but that one he
didn't really say anything about it so
his kids and then subsequently his
grandkids
were kind of like we don't know what to
do with this so for a while they just
kind of left it in the drawer because
they didn't know what to do with it
and then after then they would have like
debates over whether it should be
published or not they said all these you
know jungians kept coming to us that are
like because the red book it had like
this
you know reputation and everybody wanted
to see it
so they were kind of like well i don't
think we should and all this other stuff
so it's like they didn't want
their you know they didn't want carl
young to be
perceived as like a crazy person because
some of the stuff in there because like
i said it's almost like
i want to say it's almost like a spirit
walk or something like that because he
spent a lot of time
you know going inside himself and
coming up with all these imaginings and
stuff i don't know if he used any
psychedelics or anything like that i
don't not that i know of
but he was doing something similar to
that
where he was trying to confront his
inner demons and
just kind of so he was just like writing
down or painting
whatever imagery came to him um
in hopes of gaining some insight so some
of the stuff in there
sounds like a crazy person wrote it and
that's
i think that's kind of what his family
were worried about they didn't want
anyone perceiving him as
you know having mental problems or
anything like that but finally they did
consent to
having it published so as far as i know
i've seen like some internal pages of it
and everything like that but i guess in
2009 they finally succeeded in
you know they they flew it in like this
little i read there was a really long
article in uh the new york times
from 2009 and um i read the whole thing
and it was really interesting about
um the guy that translated it
and um he was the one that was taking it
they said they had like a special little
briefcase with all this padding in it
and stuff and they had to take it to
this place and i think it was in
california somewhere
like this high-end digital media studio
and they had to like take pictures of
each page
like in super high resolution and all
this other kind of because it's almost
it's like an illustrated manuscript it's
like really really cool looking
so you know so so it's out there now um
and as i said i don't feel like the
reason that i
find him such a fascinating character is
because he was obviously a scientist and
he had that mindset
but he also had that
he also had that kind of thing where
just this he was just fascinated by
mysticism and occultism
and um you know his whole theory of like
collective unconscious like we all
have these like this kind of myth pool
that we all draw from like all these
symbols and everything that are
you know that are the same or similar
across cultures
and across the ages all of that [ __ ] is
like really [ __ ] interesting to me
so and you know and i just find it
interesting too like
in his friendship with freud freud who
was um you know very very
uh very much a materialist um
which i guess i would be too but i can
see where the rift like came about
between the two of them
so that's like a really really
interesting uh kind of dichotomy between
the two of them and like
you know so i just i find that a really
interesting uh
kind of thing so as i said this is a
massive massive topic
i don't really have a a particular
structure
or anything about it i just kind of
wanna yeah
i was telling her i said jenny man let's
keep this [ __ ] under four hours tonight
and she's like it's gonna take as long
as it's gonna take
she told me to [ __ ] off she's like it's
gonna take i didn't tell you to [ __ ] off
that is a complete fabrication
we got joe nash said oh hold on what
then jenna
joe nash says stick around tonight tom
make yourself a home
that's cause last time i said [ __ ] it
walked out of here i wasn't feeling good
man i was sick
i was sick and he's like he's being a
douche
i caught it i was watching well i know i
didn't give a [ __ ] i was like not
feeling good man i was tired of it
he's always like and then i have to be i
have to be sitting there all by myself
going
yeah hey what's up sophie was up
violently puking up a set of acidic
vegetables
oh no oh when was just trying to chill
out
oh my god i don't know i think i guess
it was yesterday
what's happened then i don't know soph
might be coming for a visit in the next
couple months we'll see should we we
should we'll have her on the show
um let's see what's going on ken said
did you hear what they think they found
that found out what happened with the
outlaw pass yeah somebody um
somebody sent me a link to this video um
and yeah they might have figured out why
the bodies were all beat up and why
you know what i mean like what probably
killed them it was just kind of like
this
i can't remember what it's called now
it's almost kind of like a micro
avalanche an avalanche where it just
kind of like the the snow just kind of
came down over them and so
i pretty much said that though well yeah
we did and it's um
but they have like a really good um like
little computer simulation
of like what happened like i love the
computer simulation where they're
showing
like here's the weight of the snow and
this is a little body down here and this
is what happens and it's like squish
you know what i mean so i was like
that's nice tina said it said that the
red book was kubrick's
uh inspiration for directing the shiny
i know that well isn't there isn't there
a whole thing about that because
isn't there a book in allman's office
that people are like hey it's the red
book even though like i said it hadn't
been published then
but everybody knew about it like
everybody that was into that kind of
[ __ ] like knew that it existed
just nobody had seen it um hey tom i
made some
michael schaefer said hey tom i made
some um
pollock paneer and butter chicken in the
instant pot last weekend turned out
awesome
all right cool now see everybody has
been
yeah because i i read a lot of food
blogs and stuff like that because like i
said i'm fascinated by food history and
whatnot and man
everybody has gotten on this instant pot
bandwagon people are making [ __ ]
cheesecake in that [ __ ] people are
making everything in there
is it really as awesome as that or
[Music]
do you need it if we already because we
already have a crock pot
right i just make it yeah what do you
think what do you know what do you
what was the question again the instant
pot i was just saying that a lot of
people
don't need it really no i'm just saying
a lot of people really really like it
yeah because apparently it's like super
easy and you can do all this uh
kind of [ __ ] with it but we don't have
one we have a crock pot
yeah we have other kind of stuff i don't
i don't know if we can use it
to me to pots or pots i can cook in
anything you know what i mean
the only thing that's going to matter is
you know the quality of
how the dish is going to turn out and
how long how long is it going to take to
cook it
indian food takes too long to cook in a
crock pot i don't know about what
you know yeah we've never made indian
food in the crock pot we usually just
make it in like a regular pond no the
dishes aren't really set up for that
and indian cooking really isn't supposed
to take a long time
although it's better the day of the day
after and the day after that
you know it's that indian food like up
to up to a point it gets better
like every subsequent day like it's good
on the original day when you make it but
then like the next day it's really good
the next day it's even better than that
and the next day it's and then after
that it kind of starts to tina said she
saw pain again said it was hilarious
i told you it's like super funny that's
where florida is
yeah one of the most florida movies
it was miami damn although all the
cities are starting to become kind of
like miami now
like i said florida is kind of like all
the crazy gets funneled down here
it's just kind of like just all the you
know what i mean because a lot of people
it's just
a way though florida is like you know
america's wang
so everything just kind of gets funneled
down here from the bladder of the other
states like down into that i was
watching this
you guys you guys know that i like those
dead mall videos right well they got
channels out there that are basically
making dead city videos
and these guys are making videos about
all the most [ __ ] up cities in the
united states and
how the economies work and how they
don't work and
just you know even talk about
mississippi and [ __ ] you know what i
mean [ __ ] which
mississippi's a mixed bag you know it it
ranks in at the bottom
of all the statistics but a lot of that
has to do with uh
with jackson jackson kind of throws
everything
but anyway um what i was going to say is
i was going to say that
[ __ ] we should feel lucky
to live in florida compared to some of
these other [ __ ] places that you
could live in they got
well there's a lot worse so there's a
lot i'm not a big fan of florida because
like i said i was born here so i'm kind
of over it she kind of takes it for
granted but yeah
yeah but you know i can see why other
people would want to live here for sure
but you know florida reminds me you know
and you know i was born in california
florida reminds me of california in the
70s
maybe early 80s before it got really
[ __ ] crowded and really corporate
that's it's kind of reminds me of of of
california in the good old days
if you want to know what california was
like in the good old days
watch zanna do that's about what it was
like that was a pretty accurate
spiritual representation of the way it
was
yeah i mean you could go down to the
beach and you can go down to [ __ ]
venice beach and it wasn't [ __ ]
totally crowded full of people it wasn't
filled with [ __ ] tourists and [ __ ] it
was
like like fun towns and cities
you know what i mean it was it was nice
that's the way florida the florida's at
that stage now everything's on a cycle
everything you know yeah florida will
eventually get shitty it'll get worse
well yeah and some parts of florida are
already shaving yeah you know it'll
become a [ __ ] metropolis like [ __ ]
new york and then it'll run itself into
the ground eventually michael schaefer
said didn't i call
for florida satan's ass crack i did it's
hot
it's [ __ ] hot yeah in the summertime
i i really wouldn't recommend it
honestly it just seems like if people
are gonna come visit florida unless
you're super super into having swamp ass
um i would recommend it's not that bad
it is um i would recommend coming here
in like early spring or
like late fall it's a late fall it's
still hot
but it's not as crowded you won't die
of you know heat stroke every time you
walk out the door
it also gonna depend on how much money
you have that too
if you're rich you're gonna love [ __ ]
florida especially miami
south [ __ ] south miami but you got to
be a millionaire
yeah to really appreciate it yeah
although there's
good [ __ ] you don't have to be a
millionaire to appreciate miami
um if you're not a millionaire live up
around the orlando area
[ __ ] where we live it's nice you like
it yeah
it's not horribly horribly expensive
some places are but
oh it's half the price of california
yeah easily
yeah you know so you can still get
a decent amount for your money but yeah
you know i'm just saying um
so let me see what uh what else did i
have to say oh i'm not really sure
if i know we usually do um a live
matinee on sunday
but i'm not sure we're either not gonna
do one tomorrow or it'll be a lot later
because i'm gonna go
to ocala to
stop by and see my mom and
my sister who was coming down to visit
from atlanta
with her boyfriend and i was just gonna
pop in
and see them real quick because i
haven't seen them in a really long time
so i might drive over there and see them
so that's about like an hour and a half
away from here
so depending on what time i get back
because i think she's going to be there
like two in the afternoon
which means i have to leave here about
12 30. and
however long she's gonna be there i
don't really know and then i'll come
back
so we'll either do a matinee either late
later in the evening or just skip it and
do another one like on thursday when we
wouldn't normally do one you know what
i'm saying um
so we'll see how that goes did you get
so you got a movie today didn't you
i know that's that was the next thing i
was gonna say so i wanted to
give a shout out to louie we just got
this like 10 minutes before we started
the show
louis sent me the blu-ray of oculus
mike flanagan [ __ ] oh it's good
what's that about
it's about essentially it's a haunted
mirror but kinda
but um yeah it's really good i really
like i really really like this book
i saw i've seen it um but it was many
years ago
so you know mike flanagan is like a cool
[ __ ] dude and i've liked all his
movies so he was the one that did
uh he did doctor sleep didn't he yeah
yeah
i got that too house you know oh yeah we
did buy doctor sleep do we yeah i bought
a used coffee for eight bucks that's
right
blu-ray forgot all about that yeah
also didn't he do uh absentia also about
the tunnel with the thing that was like
a good movie too i think that might have
been his first one
yeah hush was good too that was the one
about the um
the woman who was deaf and
it was like a like a dude was like
stalking her like outside her house that
was like really really good
trying to get some of this alcohol into
my system man yeah you really need to
like get on the ball man trying to wake
up
wake up wake up
get that blood flowing i mean it's not
it's not like you woke up early this
morning because i don't know what it is
well yeah
i'm i'm [ __ ] i felt like i've been
beat up with a baseball bat you know
because of the sickness yeah you know
what i mean so i'm just trying to
trying to snap out of it yeah and i
haven't been real i haven't been real
[ __ ]
like uh optimistic you know what i mean
[ __ ]
i've been kind of in in the [ __ ]
dumps anyway you know
yeah um we need to get the [ __ ] out of
here and have some fun got all this
[ __ ] [ __ ] to do in florida
and well you can go with me tomorrow if
you want maybe we'll see
i don't like having to drive all that
way i know because there's no [ __ ]
there's no [ __ ] cell phone services
out there
my mom lives out in the middle of the
woods i hate making that drive i do too
but it's like that's why i don't go that
often but you know i haven't seen him in
a long time
um so you definitely need to go [ __ ]
see your people well yeah like i said i
haven't seen him in ages
stir since she moved away i haven't seen
her for a couple years and this is kind
of kind of sucks because
last year she bought me tickets to see
nick cave in atlanta
last october but of course it got
canceled because everything else did
because i was gonna do a whole road trip
and i was like gonna go up and see her
and
stay with her for a few days and stuff
like that and of course that didn't work
out
so i'm very happy that she's coming down
here she's actually going all the disney
parks her and her boyfriend
they they bought that multi-pass thing
where it's like it's a different park
every day so i don't know how much that
[ __ ] [ __ ] cost but yeah they're doing
that
so they're just like they're coming down
they're driving down and then
they're gonna stop at my mom's place and
then go on
to kissimmee and then i'm gonna go
have lunch with them like next friday
too but i wanted to see them tomorrow
because i haven't seen my mom in a long
time either
yeah they're in there talking about dr
sleep
i thought dr sleep was all right yeah i
mean it's
it's hard to i mean obviously nothing's
gonna be as good as the shining
which is like one of the best movies
ever um but i thought it was like a
decent effort
i can see how it got like mixed reviews
because some people were like man
some people i really don't like it but i
kind of feel like it
it he did the best he could i liked it
with yeah and you know what i mean and
it's like it was actually a lot better
than i was expecting
i thought when it went back to the
overlook i thought it actually picked up
a lot
i thought that was a pretty good take on
what the overlook would look like to a
[ __ ] psychic a person with a bunch of
bunch of the shining in them yeah yeah
it's all kind of
i liked it and it's good how they kind
of went in a different la and
it's weird because the movie i actually
liked the movie a little bit better
because i wasn't crazy about the book
dr sleep um because i read it not too
long before the movie came out
and i was just kind of like it's kind of
like you know
one of the more recent stephen king
books which i'm
really not that enthusiastic about you
know what i'm saying
so i just i didn't really like the book
so i thought the movie was actually like
better than the book you know i don't
usually say it's a very different tone
oh you know you're not talking about a
kubrick movie
but i thought the whole psychic vampire
angle was pretty good for the universe
yeah you know in the stephen king
universe it
made sense to me you know what i mean if
you had people that [ __ ] had the
shining did you have
[ __ ] vampires feeding on it psychic
vampires
and you know it keeps them young that's
a [ __ ] good idea i thought
well and in some ways it kind of expands
on the mythos because you could say
that the overlook hotel itself was kind
of like a psychic vampire also because
it was kind of taking energy from
people who had the shining well that's
how i that's how i thought
right the the shining was to begin with
yeah that it was a temple made
made to that [ __ ] yeah i mean on um
consecrated ground they consecrated it
with the blood of the indians
then they had like you know it was
[ __ ] evil rich people
and they had decorated their [ __ ]
basically their sacrificial temple
with like they kind of decorated it with
the artwork of all their victims you
know
i thought it was pretty good pretty cool
i know it's pretty much a sacrificial
temple
yeah like like a mayan temple temple
basically
i wrote a whole big long thing if you if
you guys have never read my blog
go to my blog goddess of hellfire and i
we we came up well he came up with like
this whole uh
thing about the shining that it's not
i mean it's not like 100 original but
it's kind of like a take on it that i
hadn't really seen before
you know what i'm saying that i hadn't
really read before um
so yeah i wrote like a big long thing
about it it's really weird because a few
days ago i got back and so
every every now and then i'll get back
into
shining conspiracy theory videos just i
don't know why i just find them
endlessly fascinating
and there's so many so just the other
day when i was working on something else
like i started watching one and i was
like that's kind of interesting i don't
know if i buy it but it's interesting
and then it just like went to another
one and i'm like oh why not i've just
you know i i've accepted that today is
just going to be a shining conspiracy
theory today like while i'm working on
[ __ ] that's what's going
on the overlook basically the overlook
was
was a child was a child island man's
island
it was like epstein's island and and
kind of like something from [ __ ]
what was that uh eyes wide shut thank
you dan
thanks dan yeah
official temple to pervs rich powerful
perverts
well it was a place you could go that no
one was looking at you where you could
kind of indulge your worst impulses
but and get away with it but in another
dimension it was sucking all that [ __ ]
up
yeah well and that's i i kind of feel
like that was implicit in
your theory was that the hotel itself
was
in essence alive and was kind of
it drew those kind of people to it
because it wanted the energy it wanted
to feed off of all the
that horrible negative [ __ ] that was
happening
so that's i mean that made complete and
total sense to me
yeah i saw one the other day and i was
telling you about this it was i don't
think that i buy this but it was
interesting anyway and somebody made
like an hour long video about it so i
was kind of like yeah whatever
somebody made a video saying that i
can't remember who it was now
but saying that if you watch the movie
through the lens
of wendy is the one that has
mental issues and that some of the stuff
in the movie that's happening is her
hallucination they kind of
marshalled a lot of evidence where
they're they're like you know all the
weird [ __ ] that happens like you know
there's that really famous scene where
jack is in the um
you know in his office or whatever like
in the in that big room and like the
chairs behind him and then it's not
behind him
and it's like so they're talking about
all these kind of supposed
inconsistencies like oh now here this
here's a light switch and now there's
not a light switch
and all the [ __ ] about the um you know
the uh the geography of the hotel being
all like [ __ ] askew and everything
so they're saying well every time you
see a shot where
something like a light switch that was
there
is not there anymore then what you're
seeing is
subjective from wendy's hallucination
like wendy is imagining all this she's
the one that
um strangled danny in the room she's the
one that did this and that
and like i said so i'm watching the
video and i'm like i'm not sure i buy
this but it's a pretty
it's a no but it was a pretty compelling
case that they made even though i don't
believe it i think it's a reach
we know the original story yeah know
what the [ __ ] kubrick was doing
we know there are mistakes in the edit
that's all that's all it is
the chair thing was just a mistake in
the edit thank you tila
thanks t gotta take off now but have a
great show
okay yeah fine have a good time well you
can watch it later t
yeah it'll it'll up all these babies i'm
gonna have to get another drink
yeah i still have like a quarter one
left but yeah
so i don't know it's just one of those
things
man the shining is like the one movie
that i've never i don't think i ever
ever get tired of it if
somebody said right now hey wanna watch
the shining yeah
which i don't i can't think of that many
other movies that
that have that same kind of rewatch
ability and i see something different in
it every single time
but it's weird because i didn't really
realize i know there was like the chair
thing and all that kind of crap but
i didn't realize you know there's
there's [ __ ] like
you know like when halloran like is
showing uh wendy and danny around the
big kitchen
and like here's the freezer the dry good
storage or whatever
and it's like then there's a light
switch there but then later
there's not one and i'm sitting there
thinking okay
like kubrick well for one thing the
whole inside the whole interior of the
overlook in the movie
is a set so i don't understand
how that could have been done um
accidentally
that oh we shot this and it's like
there's a light switch and then there's
not a light switch like how does that
happen
i just kind of feel like he did all that
[ __ ] on purpose
although i don't think that it's because
he was trying to signal hey this is all
wendy's hallucination like this person
was trying to argue
i think that kubrick did do it on
purpose but i think that he only did it
to disorient um
the viewer i kind of feel like that's
what he was going for
because i think that's the reason that
he made the overlook
not like the the architecture of it the
interior of it doesn't make sense
like where the windows are like where
the hallways go [ __ ] like that
it doesn't make any sense i think he
just did that like to be
like you know what i mean yeah as a um
goddamn okay that's just strong
well you're the one that made it what
are you yelling at me for
i think he just did it as a
disorientation tactic you know what i'm
saying
it was awesome yeah okay
see what's going on here
yeah bee's nest says poultry guys never
gets old either
that's a good movie yeah i can watch
that over and over
i mean yeah there are certain movies
that i don't know for some reason i just
i just never get sick of the shining
never i've probably seen it a hundred
times over my life
and you know like i was telling them i
said even you said right now if you want
to watch it i'd totally wonder michael
says i can watch marked for death
anytime
[ __ ] mark oh my god
actually you know what i was getting
ready to [ __ ] watch again i was
getting ready to watch under siege
two electric boogaloo yeah under siege
too
actually i like under siege that's
[ __ ] that's that's i don't even know
if i did
that's the best movie well yeah but
under siege two wasn't that bad
it's just that it had a really shitty
villain wait what happened
what happened in part two part two he's
on a train
and he's trying to stop uh terrorists
that are on the train that are
gonna gonna uh activate a damn killer
satellite basically that's what it is
it's not ringing and the guy's supposed
to be some kind of a the villain is like
a computer genius
but it doesn't it didn't it didn't age
well
you know just didn't age well but it's
just more segal being seagal
him [ __ ] flirting with his niece
he's uncle uncle [ __ ] uncle [ __ ]
rybach or whatever his name was
reebok and they're like dude that's your
[ __ ] niece
and he's like well you know man you know
how [ __ ] skeevy is he's skeevy in the
[ __ ]
thank you victor yeah
and then like uh i don't know
he for real like now see i must not have
seen part two because
yeah steven seagal skeeving on his niece
i definitely would have remembered that
yeah i don't think you've ever seen it
sounds like i'm not really missing
anything
no i've only seen it once
it's like what she's only kind of
related yeah she's probably only half my
age
yeah oh yeah she's like [ __ ] 19.
he's probably about i don't know close
to 40.
stop it steven seagal well some guys i
can buy that there are certain rock
stars that are out there that are
[ __ ] you know had had away with you
know like a [ __ ] 40 year old [ __ ]
david bowie and a
20 year old [ __ ] chick and yeah that
[ __ ] was going down of course that would
happen
but that was david bowie you're not
talking about steven seagal
that's what i mean i don't i don't think
it's even so much the age
it's it's the person that it is it's the
person that it is
yeah i mean i'm not saying like i i just
david bowie just never came across as
creepy to me
no you know what i mean steven seagal
just comes across as super crazy there
were some dudes that were [ __ ]
older they were just [ __ ] slinging
mad [ __ ] fussy man [ __ ] all what
[ __ ] uh uh [ __ ]
dude from rolling stones with whom i
think mick jagger mick jagger
yeah i mean he's ancient now yeah but
when mick jagger was in his 40s or 50s
that dude was still a man
i mean [ __ ] you know he was
he had a lot of girlfriends i think he
was married by that time but
probably yeah you know even though
[ __ ] you know
whatever nick jagger whatever
i'm still gonna [ __ ] just give it to
[ __ ] um
david bowie though you know what i'm
talking about well i feel like
hard to top that [ __ ] david
bowie could get away with a lot
just because he was david bowie he was
david [ __ ] bowie
all right he could do whatever he wanted
and he kind of came across as
not really as being something like
greater than human
yeah well he wasn't scavy that's what
i'm saying
he never gave me like a creepy vibe by
any stretch of the imagination he was
he was a [ __ ] strange gentleman but
he was still a gentleman
yeah yeah you didn't get that like
[ __ ] chester the molester vibe
like you get from steven seagal and he
was
although uh truth be told back in the
studio 54 era
he was dating i think like a 14 or a 15
year old girl
yeah did you know about that she was a
fan i heard about that yet she was a
famous club girl you know
back in the 70s it wasn't quite the same
you know what i mean [ __ ] uh
age wasn't a big issue they were all
[ __ ] high
she wasn't old enough to be in a club
anyway but she was everybody knew
she was super famous scenester and
she was dating bowie for a while he was
i think she was what 14
15. something like that and he would
but he wasn't that much older than her
let's be honest yeah
yeah i mean mid to late 20s maybe yeah i
mean it would be weirder
and he's like going after teenagers
that's not like always problematic
i've seen pictures of her i saw pictures
of her she didn't look underage she just
looked like everybody else
yeah she she looked 18
officer we're boarding they didn't give
a [ __ ] back then they're not
selling so much [ __ ] cocaine at the
studio 54 and that's why the place got
shut down if i remember correctly
among uh yeah
well is it i feel like 70s and 80s
there were no rules well and i mean
everybody was [ __ ] choked up around
that i didn't know i didn't know what
the hell is going on
so yeah so you have to give people a
little bit of leeway it's like
we were so coked up we didn't know what
the [ __ ] was going on but uh
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] bowie
can't believe that dude died well that's
how it goes
but you know what that [ __ ] [ __ ]
died pretty he did
he looked good his whole life i'm like
i might have mentioned this before but
it's like i'm not one of those people
that's like gets bummed out about
celebrities dying or anything like that
but
david bowie dying really really that
really [ __ ] me up
it really really that really really
upset me he was he was
basically an old man when i was in high
school when i was in high school he was
in his 40s
and i considered that to be an old man
but you know back then
now you're now at 51 if you got 40 yeah
that's what it's a yeah
that's a little old well
arnold was [ __ ] 41 during predator
one
he doesn't look like an old man does it
he was like 40 41.
well that's the thing that when you're
young everybody seems like an old person
yeah you know what i mean like when
you're a teenager it's like somebody's
30 and they're like oh my god they're
[ __ ] ancient
because i remember i remember feeling
like that too yeah so
they everybody does
[Laughter]
somebody says doesn't everyone go
through a coke phase
and then bismuth says i'm still in my
coke face
i didn't go through a coke phase did she
leave where'd you go
yeah talking about [ __ ] angela bowie
and [ __ ] mick jagger and all that
nobody knows what's true during that
time those people [ __ ] made up
stories about each other to [ __ ]
magnify their legend yeah well yeah
they were very based on nothing they
understood branding back then and they
were just kind of like hey man
yeah the craziest [ __ ] that we can come
up with it's like the better
they had fanzines back then you know
there was no internet
so that [ __ ] would kind of come out in
fanzines music fanzines
but you never knew what was true because
they would lie on purpose
they put all kinds of crazy press out
you know
well yeah because it got them pressed
that was the whole point like it didn't
matter if it was bad press or good press
or whatever as long as it was press and
they understood that back then too yep
so you know
you just made [ __ ] up so should we go
ahead and start this [ __ ]
yeah we're gonna we're gonna talk about
carl young yeah we're gonna just talk
about carl yo
you know some [ __ ] about this don't you
do you not you do all right
um okay so let's talk a little bit about
kind of his biography a little and then
talk a little bit about kind of the
context of the time i suppose
because i guess it's really weird to
think about nowadays
but the [ __ ] that we talk about now in
psychology like a lot of the formative
ideas that people have about psychology
not really a big thing like until
you know freud and young and stuff like
that came along
yeah and i feel like their ideas even
though a lot of their ideas have been
you know kind of fallen by the wayside
like as far as like scientific circles
go
but they're but they've really kind of
leached into the public consciousness to
such an extent
that i think that people don't even
realize that that's that they came from
like a single person or
a group of people yeah let's straighten
something out before we talk about
this any further
psychology is not really a science it's
never been a science
um it's a lot closer to a philosophy
because you can't really prove what
people are thinking it's hard to prove
things that psychology talks about
it's almost kind of like a high class
scientology
scientology is actually l ron hubbard
was trying to replace psychology
and get scientology put in universities
that's how [ __ ] crazy that
[ __ ] was
but it's not as crazy as you think when
you
look at psychology psychology is pretty
[ __ ] crazy too
but it's not a it's not a science
it it's a philosophy i mean psychiatry
has
more it's more of a science it's more of
a science because that actually does
deal with you know the structures of the
brain how does this structure the brain
affect people's behavior blahdy blah
whereas psychology is much more nebulous
when i was a little kid psychiatrists
looked at psychologists in the same way
we would look at a [ __ ] scientologist
they just say that
yeah because they're just like ah stop
it that's not that you know you can't
prove any of that that's not real
that's not a science and um psychology
is
is not as it's not a hard science now
doesn't necessarily mean that what
psycholo what what psychology says like
some of the things that psycho
some of us some of the theories
psychology has
doesn't mean that there isn't anything
to it i mean their
psychology will talk about personality
types and you can look at it and go yeah
there are personalities like that that
person does fit that personality type
but that's not really saying much when
you think about it i mean
think about it astrology does that too
i'm a cancer i'm a sagittarius oh i'm
such a libra
and then some of that [ __ ] does sound
like it kind of fits
but it's fortune cookie stuff but
there is some use to psych psychology i
would think
there there's there's something to it
it's just that it's
it's not a science it's an art form yeah
and i think the thing too
is that some people do find benefit
in you know going to an analyst
say yeah and you know particularly a
young ian
analyst and having their dreams
interpreted and so you know and
maybe that makes them you know
feel better that maybe that makes them a
better person so i do feel like it has
some value but like you said that it's
not like a hard science no i mean you
could go
lay down a table and [ __ ] do auditing
too they say the [ __ ] audit they love
scientologists love auditing they say
there's something to it
that it makes you feel good but talking
to people makes you feel good that's
what that's
well talking about yourself everybody
likes to talk about themselves
i think that's you know yeah that that
just might be the most cynical
interpretation but i do feel like people
people love to talk about themselves and
feel like someone is listening to them
for yourself and validating their if
you're self-absorbed you might want to
consider becoming a scientologist
just don't join church of scientology
become a free scientologist
a lot cheaper although you can get the
ot materials for free
although you might get some of the
squirrel busters showing up on your
doorstep
squirrel busters yeah
you gotta be a real fan of the show to
know what we're talking about there
just look at squirrel busters on youtube
you'll see it's knocking
see marty is you know where is marty
oh man i kind of and as i said i felt
like this when i worked for them too
i just to me it seems like scientology
yeah
is a bunch of it's um
well it seems like a bunch of
kindergartners who think that they're
grown-ups
yeah that's kind of like how it comes
across to me
i don't know they just come across as
like a bunch of children like
play-acting as adults but they play
acting
as um mentally challenged adults
let's put it that way that's uh that's
how kind of i interpreted that
they're telling me to put a feather in
my hat and call it macaroni
you totally you should it's my bush hat
it makes me sexy
[Laughter]
it's magical like that yeah
all right so um so carl young
so he's born in switzerland now in 1875.
now it should be noted that as i said
when he was born
this was kind of um you know in
in a time prior to psychology even being
a thing
i think that it didn't really gain its
footing until about 20 years later
uh you know with freud kind of coming on
the scene and
as i said we'll talk about that a little
bit later because there was a big
um you know the two of the two of them
they're the relationship between the two
of them a lot of their ideas are very
similar but they had like a very famous
rift and you know looking at the way
that they
looked at things differently is kind of
uh instructive probably
so yeah so he's born in 1875. now
his parents were actually pretty poor
um his dad i think he had started out as
a linguist and he was like really good
at it but for some reason he just didn't
have a lot of [ __ ]
gumption or a lot of go-getter whatever
and uh
so him and the whole family are kind of
poor um
so the dad is like a minister now
the mom seems to have had some
kind of mental issues
let's call it that um i think carl young
said later on that
his mom would act totally normal during
the daytime but then at night time she
acted like super weird like she would
act like really
weird and messaged she'd be like
creeping around the house and like
acting really bizarro
i think he even said i was like reading
a couple different biographies of him
like on
kindle unlimited and i think he even
said at one point
that he's like one time i saw this
figure coming out of my mom's room one
night that was like this
glowing woman with like no head well she
had a head but like the head was like
in front of the body you know what i
mean like the head was up here and like
the body is by like a ghosty
kind of [ __ ] or something and like he
kind of associated that with his mom
so i so his mom like had some issues
um you know to depression like whatever
the other
[ __ ] going on was so i kind of feel like
this
whole dynamic might have played into his
[ __ ] later on because he did have a
thing where
i don't want to say he wasn't like
misogynistic or anything like that even
like for the time
but i think that he saw women as
unreliable just because of what his mom
was like but he saw
men as kind of like strong and decisive
but
ultimately useless because his dad was
kind of
useless you know what i mean because he
couldn't really it's a different world
make any money yeah so i think that that
like
kind of informed a lot of his later
views it would have looked that way
though
think about it because you had us you
had a society where
women basically they weren't that
educated maybe they had some
school you know when they were in high
school probably wasn't much
but you're raising all these guys who
are like the head of the household and
they gotta [ __ ] keep [ __ ] under
control
and you know what i mean oh yes don't no
not at my table
you know what i mean so they're kind of
like your local governor
but they're only in charge of the house
yeah government's [ __ ]
treating them like [ __ ] though you
know in the off hours
telling them what to do so when you're a
kid they seem powerful
but they're not powerful versus the
government the government's boss them
around
and then your mom and your sisters
they're just
your sisters are just women that get
married off their girls to get married
after some dudes
yeah i mean and your your mom is just
somebody who
takes care of the children you know i
mean she doesn't have much of a role
outside of that
so you know most countries are like that
you know south america is a lot like
that you know
it's i guess it's very it's very defined
gender roles i don't know if it's like
that anymore but it was when i was
growing up there in the 80s
you know women just um
would be you know they're kind of like
what he's talking about you know what i
mean they're just
[ __ ] they kind of come off as uh
thank you cat being under the thumb of
other people
and they don't have much power on their
own there's not much to them they're
housewives
yeah that's how they come across but
he's saying this from the point of view
of a kid though
you know what i mean yeah of a child
growing up in this environment
probably wouldn't look that way to
another adult though but it's
for it's formative well yeah
and i i kind of feel like both young and
freud
i think they may be i don't know i don't
want to say they checked a lot
well yeah and i don't want to say they
overestimate because [ __ ] that happens
to you
in your childhood is obviously very
formative to like
you know it does like form a lot of the
basis of your um you know your opinions
later on
yeah but you go back and look at it it's
not realistic yeah i do think that
maybe they put a lot more emphasis on
there than perhaps
was warranted yeah because i do feel
like
what it really was and i always thought
that these guys
because he even as a kid i would read
about
carl jung and [ __ ] [ __ ]
what's his name [ __ ] uh freud freud
and they're always talking about
childhood development and as a teenager
i'm like man these [ __ ] are
hung up on some really [ __ ] childish
[ __ ]
really you know what i mean because even
even at the age of 15 or 16
i was looking at that going like that's
kind of weird
that they've kind of hung up on this
[ __ ]
i think they were just kind of men of
their times and they're [ __ ] yeah
they're looking into [ __ ] they looked
too deeply into things if you ask me
if you went back and probably looked at
his mom and looked at his dad it was
just
desperate people trying to survive
that's all it was yeah i mean
particularly his family because they
were kind of broke dick
um because his dad was you know a kind
of a
small town person essentially yeah
um they did actually move to somewhere a
little bit like he got a little bit
better
[ __ ] later on but i do kind of feel like
i do kind of feel well and it could be
too that people
are you know hindsight is 20 20.
yeah and if you look back at someone's
childhood and then you look at their
subsequent
development that you know especially
when they're really famous or they're
really famous for a particular
you know psychological type of thing so
i feel like
maybe how they were brought up is
given a lot more more weight weight
than maybe it would have otherwise yeah
um you know i know that you know my
memory of things
when i was a kid don't really match up
with reality
like you know i'll remember a place a
certain way and if you go back there
later on you're like oh that's all it
was i remember this place being a lot
bigger more
more important looking yeah it looked
bigger and more important to you because
you were [ __ ]
because you were little 13 or 14 at the
time just
just another mundane place you know what
i mean
and your [ __ ] upbringing was just
kind of
normal for the situation you know what i
mean it seemed real
important to you when you were a kid
because that was the first time you did
some [ __ ]
that's really weird well yeah and things
do seem a lot more important to you when
you're a kid just because that's kind of
the nature of being a kid
everything is just like a big deal
because it's like you said it's the
first time you're being exposed to
certain things certain concepts whatever
so it's gonna seem like a lot more
significant but then when you go back
and revisit it
it's just kind of like you know stuff
that i
found like a really big deal when i was
little like whether it was a movie or
whether it was a place i went or
something like that and then you go back
and see it later
you're like well and it's completely not
the same as what you remembered it as
because you like built up this big
[ __ ] structure around it in your head
and that's not at all what it was like
to me a lot of psychology freudian
psychology is that
building up a lot of [ __ ] into your head
yeah and i do kind of feel like i'm
gonna give
i mean although i understand like you
know neither one
neither freud nor young um even though
we talk about them a lot
still like in psychology and whatnot um
you know but in real you know like i
said scientific circles they're kind of
a lot of their ideas have kind of fallen
by the wayside but i can see
why there was such a rift between the
two of them and
in that sense i would give young the
upper hand because
freud i feel like oh my goodness what's
that
they're abducting them children oh [ __ ]
man do we is it was that an amber alert
yeah leave them chilling
i didn't get one on my phone usually i
get one on my phone because i restarted
it
okay um but i do feel like
freud was way too focused on
sexuality i thought i think yeah i think
he felt like everything
could be um you know kind of
it was a very reductive way of looking
at things
yeah because it's like everything every
neurosis that you have
yeah can be kind of distilled down to
some like sexual [ __ ]
yes and i think even and it's weird
because even
when young was around um other
colleagues of freud were starting to say
that too so it's not just a modern thing
that we're casting back here even at the
time
too much they were just kind of like
yeah i just think that that's too it's
too
narrow of focus so like even back then
people were saying yeah
i've noticed that he was always coming
up with [ __ ] [ __ ] about [ __ ]
oedipus complexes with your mom and
[ __ ] toy training stuff
yeah and you know
it's kind of like it's it's kind of odd
you know what i mean when you think
about it it's very odd it's just
as odd as [ __ ] as l ron hubbard
yeah you know ron hubbard was saying
everything goes back to the fact that
your mom tried to kill you
when you were in the womb
ain't that some [ __ ] because all mom's
trying all moms are trying to kill you
when you're in the womb that was [ __ ]
happy that was l wrong
hubbard's uh explanation for why you're
so [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
and are like that that happened in l ron
hubbard's imagination
yeah you know what i mean and and then
he's he's he's [ __ ] projecting that
into everybody else's imagination that
has always been
your mama tried to kill you when you
were in the womb i'm like maybe
your mama did yeah yeah well he thought
yeah i think so therefore you know so
therefore
everybody's well seen that's that's your
problem right there
i think the the main problem with that
way of thinking which is maybe why it
strikes me is so very funny is that your
experiences uh to a large extent cannot
be universalized
um other people's uh other people are
different from you
news flash so it's like just because you
experienced this when you were growing
up just because your parents suck just
because
this happened to you or you had this
particular that's your thing
you can't generalize that to everybody
yeah and another thing is just like just
because when you were a kid you got
into a fight with some other kids and
you somehow got embarrassed or something
that doesn't mean those kids even
remember
that [ __ ] happening yeah you know what i
mean
and that's that's that same thing
everyone's [ __ ]
experience of childhood is very
different from other people's experience
of childhood
yeah your childhood experiences are
unique and they're also not
accurate the the way you remember [ __ ]
is not how it happened
yeah because you were a kid you were a
kid you don't have the ability your
brain's kind of amorphous
you don't have the ability to remember
things accurately
and you remembered things in an intense
way
only because it was intense for you at
that time yeah
yeah but it wasn't if you were to see it
happen to another kid
you're like oh that's all it was yeah
yeah let me get you another drink
yeah it's like that's the thing it's
like you know and
i think that's really it maybe it's it's
kind of like a lot uh i think it's a lot
better now because
people are a lot more aware that
everyone's
perceptions everyone's experiences are
different and
it's like unique to them but i do feel
like particularly back then
um you had some [ __ ] up [ __ ] happen to
you in childhood and all of a sudden
you're gonna grow up and generalize it
and
suddenly everybody has that now and
that's the explanation for everything
and you're gonna like
write books and a whole [ __ ] theory
about it but you know i don't
i don't know if you would necessarily do
that nowadays but you know
um so yeah where was i so
carl young uh not surprisingly
was a pretty uh introverted kid
now as i said it does seem
like he had some i guess he got picked
on and bullied a little bit like that
because his family was
poor um you know among a lot of the
other families in the area
and um you know his mom suffered from
depression and various other things so
that might have affected
uh his outlook as well now
an interesting thing that he seems to
have developed quite early on and i
don't think that he was oh thanks i
don't think he was particularly
secretive about it either
was that he almost developed i don't
want to call it a split personality
because it wasn't exactly that
it was kind of like he was like well one
part of me
is just this you know normal person
growing up in switzerland in this time
period
the other part of him was like and he
was a kid at the time like a kid a
teenager
but the other part of him was which he
called
personality number two was like
a wise old man but like from the 18th
century
like he was picturing him with like the
buckle shoes and the wig and all that
kind of stuff
so he kind of thought i don't know if he
thought of it
literally like that but he almost kind
of thought of it like he had two
personalities in one body like he was
like a kid or a teenager that was like a
modern swiss citizen
and then he had this other persona or
this other part of his personality which
was like a wise old man
from the past you know what i mean so he
had that kind of whole thing going on
now um one thing happened
so as i said he was very into even as a
kid
he was really into esoteric kind of [ __ ]
he really
liked coming up with like little things
that were like
i don't know a ceremonial or he he took
great delight in that type of thing i
guess because he didn't really have a
lot of
you know a lot of friends or he was very
quiet or whatever
so he kind of like
really got into making his own
symbols or making his own little
ceremonies giving meaning
to his own type of like little
activities in that sort of way
now one thing that happened to him when
he was about 12 years old
so he's at this school in um
basil switzerland right
and this other boy pushes him down on
the ground
and he apparently whacks his head really
hard like on this [ __ ]
part of the curb or whatever and it
knocks him out for a little while
now he was not a big fan of school
prior to this um he was kind of one of
those kids where
it seemed like i mean obviously he was
very intelligent
but it seemed like he used a great deal
of his intelligence in trying to avoid
work rather than rather than just like
doing the work and getting it over with
you know what i'm saying
like he he he expended a lot of his
uh energy and intelligence and like
shirking you know what i'm saying like
getting around stuff
so when he um fell on the ground and got
knocked out he said that the first thing
that he thought when he woke up from
being unconscious
was hey i don't have to go to school
anymore now
because like i said he hated school and
he didn't want to do any work
um so as it happened that did kind of
work out for him for a little while
because what would happen was that
every time that he would go to school or
every time that he would think about
school work he would pass out
so i'm sure it was like some kind of
hysterical kind of thing
or whatever because he wasn't into it
hold on one second beezness in there
[ __ ] with me
beezness shut the [ __ ] up bro trying to
[ __ ] do the show
he keeps [ __ ] [ __ ] what are you
saying just
drinking with my [ __ ] hat and my
[ __ ] big head and [ __ ] your big
head
[ __ ] open my fly and pop this big ass
[ __ ] head out
mexico won't save you [ __ ] goes to
mexico
[ __ ] every [ __ ] week working down
in mexico
chasing them [ __ ] mexican girls
where's my tequila [ __ ] what did he say
he was gonna say
telling me i'm gonna send you some
tequila that [ __ ] didn't [ __ ] send
me up tequila cheap ass [ __ ]
okay go ahead oh my god you're getting
so cranky he's already getting cranky
because i'm drunk and fussy no i got
[ __ ] i got to do i'm trying to finish
this [ __ ] show
dude we just started i know i mean an
hour ago we started an hour ago i know
but you know well you know the more you
help me talk about carl young the
the sooner we can get this over with if
that's what you want
i'm having a good time i don't know
i'm good they're in there laughing now
yeah i forgot about your tequila's he
says man shut the [ __ ]
i didn't forget about my tequila goes to
mexico every [ __ ] day
saying oh my goodness place is like a
wash with tequila yeah i'm gonna get you
some tequila and then
[ __ ] man then he shows me what tequila
is gonna get me some [ __ ]
bojack ass cheap ass [ __ ] rod gut
tequila this man [ __ ] keep that [ __ ]
down there
if you're gonna send me some [ __ ]
tequila that shit's gonna be some dude
if you're gonna send me [ __ ] tequila
i i'm in [ __ ]
florida all right we got good tequila
here i'm [ __ ] drinking exotico right
now
the best tequila in mexico
ass [ __ ] con of otsulon or ask him
he's gonna say some alagro
milagro that's what they [ __ ] drink
which you can get that here we'll get
that here that's next enough
they sell it everywhere you're gonna
give me some decay to give me some
[ __ ] craft tequila
something where some [ __ ] ricardo
montebron [ __ ] dipped his nuts
in that [ __ ] before it went over there
like that
it's like some special [ __ ] yeah yeah he
did something to that you know
some craft [ __ ] you know what i would
love it
if somebody made a craft tequila and
that was the whole commercial
was just somebody like dipping his nuts
in it and then going
yeah and he does the [ __ ] in slow motion
yeah yeah yeah
they even got it like that like that
these shakes
i mean i would totally buy that come on
so yeah i know you would
so would you no come on that's funny it
is funny
[Laughter]
i wouldn't drink it maybe i buy i
wouldn't drink it be like man it had
your nuts in it
yeah but did it really they're just
they're just trying to make a funny
commercial
but on my nuts i rubbed some good
habanero juice on it before i would
see well yeah that's yeah it's like some
habanero [ __ ]
you know what i kind of feel like you
could probably find it like a nice
shore nuts for that kind of stuff what's
that you could probably find a niche
market for that kind of stuff oh yeah
it'd be like some kind of [ __ ]
you can sell any [ __ ] [ __ ]
thing on the internet i'm just telling
you
be some kind of as long as you can like
afford to make a funny ass commercial
look how well the [ __ ] oh now they're
going tequila with cheese
showing up and they just got in from
mexico
yeah tom likes tea bag tequila yes so
signing up for that commercial yeah
i mean i i'm gonna tell you right now
like louie's going it's good louis
hernandez
i mean if you like really do a funny
commercial
ken says we're nuts about our tequila
yes easy
that's awesome the [ __ ] tagline itself
is an awesome tagline
i'm telling you these nuts tequila
that's what koket says yeah
god damn it's kind of like like i said
look at all the
like the funniest [ __ ] commercials
well that i thought were fun i don't see
a lot of commercials i only just see
them if they go viral because i don't
watch a lot of
you know i don't watch any tv or
anything but it's like look at the [ __ ]
like what was that squatty potty type of
thing with like the [ __ ]
uh the unicorn that like [ __ ] out little
poops but that looked like
uh you know soft serve ice cream yeah
okay they had that
you had your poo pourri commercials
hilarious um
also i'm a big fan of the [ __ ]
uh squatch they're like handmade soaps
if you guys haven't seen those i don't
know how well this business is doing but
those commercials
are hysterical those are the only
commercials that i'll actually
like if it's in front of a youtube video
i'll just watch the whole commercial i
don't care if it's two minutes long
because that [ __ ] is [ __ ] funny
you know what i mean um there's like
soap for men
someone just and they lean right into it
like they talk about your [ __ ] nuts
and your sad
like withered balls and also oh my god
so so
so funny yeah they're so funny they just
like make me laugh every single time i
see them
so like i said if you're gonna go that
way then just
go all in with the [ __ ] i like it better
that because remember back in the old
days
you know if you had commercials for like
maxi pads or some [ __ ] like that
and it's like they always had to be all
cagey about it like look we're pouring
some
blue liquid into this maxi pad to show
you that it works even though that's
totally not it's like looks like water
down windex or whatever because
yeah it's like we can't show like the
real thing
which i'm not saying that you
necessarily have to do that but it was
pretty
i guess but it's just it really does
seem like i like nowadays that they're
willing to just kind of
show [ __ ] the way it really is you know
what i mean instead of like being all
euphamists there was a lot of missed
opportunities i mean
when it came to marketing now we're
getting off subject but that's all right
that's what we always do
it was like uh you know i'm a big billy
idol fan especially back in the day you
know
he hasn't made any good [ __ ] albums
in a while but
hey you know i mean rock stars have they
have a they have a [ __ ] sell by date
but remember the song breville yell yeah
he was talking about a whiskey called
rebel yell yeah why wasn't there a
[ __ ] marketing campaign
for rebel yell whiskey at that time i
mean it was rotgut but they should have
just rolled with it and made that yeah
[ __ ] wrote on those coattails yeah
they should have made that like the punk
rock [ __ ]
rebel yell whiskey even though it was a
northern company that owned that brand
and it was like some
kind of [ __ ] two-bit two-bit
distillery that was making that [ __ ] at
that time
man they could have cashed in i should
have cashed in man
i would love to have some rebel yell
whiskey [ __ ] getting drunk as [ __ ]
[ __ ] listening to that [ __ ] billy
album
with a rebel yeah
yeah sophie says now the pad commercials
and [ __ ] cleaners are pretty
much no filter from what i say on
youtube see i like that better because i
don't like this euphemistic
oh we're being so cute it's like look
we're pouring like blue [ __ ] into the
i'm like that's not what that's for why
are you
if you remember how mainstream
television
was i know it used to like it used to
piss me off it was television
so we're so happy now that like she's a
generic
generic generic and now they're like
they don't care who they offend so
that's good
look i was telling you people earlier on
what happened to [ __ ] mississippi
what destroyed the [ __ ] culture of
the south
i was there i was [ __ ] there i know
it destroyed mississippi
it was [ __ ] mtv mtv and cable
television
well yeah because they're like oh my god
that's what the world looks like okay
it's like a lot better than what we have
going on here bye
in mississippi every [ __ ] kid that i
knew that was growing up with in
mississippi they're all gone they all
left this
they all left the south because of mtv
you know and now you have mississippi a
[ __ ] collapsing
[ __ ] shrinking [ __ ] uh um
uh shrinking [ __ ] population you know
what i mean with a [ __ ]
it's just there's no reason to be there
but back in the day there was a reason
to be in these little places
you they had people that were just
growing up and living their whole lives
in these little towns
happy you know their own little local
cultures and local economies all gone
all gone and um
in a weird way it's kind of sad you know
in a weird way
it's kind of sad everybody move into
these [ __ ] lar everybody's
moving to large suburbs basically that's
that's the future but there was you know
i was there the [ __ ] small town life
it was like little mayberries
you know what i mean there was a it was
a reality unto itself
you could have a little retail job you
know all gone now
yeah i don't know it's it's kind of like
that whole kind of [ __ ] is a
double-edged sword like i'm all kind of
i get like you know yes we like our
local community and yes we like
you know it's the flavor that it has
which is like nowhere else
but small towns also have a really
dark side of hey we don't like anybody
that's different
and we don't like you know what i mean
so it's kind of like a you know that
wasn't the problem
the problem was nepotism that was the
real problem
if you weren't related to the right
people you'd never get the good jobs
well that too that was really the main
problem
but you know what i mean each little
community had its own thing
and they were all interrelated to begin
with anyway
you can't democratize reality cat says
now it's all really meth berries
yeah it's real but it doesn't matter
where you go whatever country you know
you know if you go to india everybody's
indian it's just it was to say it's the
same thing
when you went to mississippi everybody
was from mississippi mississippi
they were all mississippian yeah yeah
um yeah so where was i okay so um
right so little carl like i said he gets
knocked out
and then wakes up and says hey this
means i don't have to go to school
anymore
um so he was very excited about that
because he didn't really like school and
he just wanted to like skive off all the
time
now so he basically just did that for a
while because he got out of school for
like six months
by just like passing out every time he's
oh i'm going to school oh my god i'm
going to pass out because like dudes
back then are drama queens you know
so i just kind of feel like from reading
a lot of victorian era literature
the dudes back then mean
they just like passed out all the
[ __ ] time you know what i mean
where no i'm just saying like all the
like i read a lot of victorian fiction
yeah they fainted a lot yeah yeah and
it's and so i feel like they were just
so delicate
i think they [ __ ] faked it
to get out of doing [ __ ] they didn't
want to do well i think that's kind of
what carl was
uh was going for he just like every time
he was like going to school he's like oh
god i'm so ill but
he would like to pass out so he didn't
have to go because he didn't want to go
to school
i think that's why i think fainting was
basically virtue signaling
oh my god i'm shocked i'm shocked i
can't take this
i'm clutching my pearls oh my god it's
too much summoned my fainting couch
yeah that's what it was yeah it's just
some people were saying well some people
said well it was because their
courses all their clothes were too tight
i don't think so i think it was well
that might have been part well where
women were concerned that might have
been partially because i've worn corsets
a lot and
i could see that happening yeah but i've
known some gothic girls that were
[ __ ] just corseted as [ __ ] with the
little bitty tiny waists
and as long as you [ __ ] ratcheted it
up slowly well
yeah but that's the thing you had to
like slowly work up to that
i think it was all what you would call
today virtue
signaling you see something you don't
like
so you faint and that proved to everyone
else that you were a
how shocked you were yeah i can't even
deal with this right yeah i can't deal
with that [ __ ] my consciousness is
checking out that's right i'm gone
i'm having an outer body
[Laughter]
[ __ ] probably [ __ ] well and like
i said i think in carl's case it
probably was because like i said he
didn't really like going to school he
wasn't
um he wasn't i don't know i don't i
don't know if i'd call him lazy
necessarily but he wasn't
a real like you know oh let's do all the
school work or anything
so i kind of feel like that he liked to
get out of uh school work when he could
so when he had the head injury he kind
of had an excuse so i do kind of feel
like he was fainting sometimes when
maybe
physically he didn't really need to but
so he did that for a while he got out of
going to school for like six months
and then he didn't really get his [ __ ]
together until
allegedly and he said this later on he
overheard his dad
talking about him one day like his dad
was basically saying because his dad was
a minister and he was [ __ ] broke and
he was getting broker as
days went on and the dad was kind of
like man
i'm getting broke um the kid probably
has
epilepsy he's like i don't know how this
kid's gonna support himself when he gets
older
and i'm just like at a loss as to what
he's gonna do
and carl said that that was the first
time that he had ever considered
that he would have to make a living of
his own someday
and that scared the [ __ ] out of him so
apparently he got his
crap together and didn't really faint
anymore after that which like i said
just kind of leads me to believe that it
was probably [ __ ] to start with or
just
like in a way of getting out of [ __ ] and
he just like went
he buckled right the [ __ ] down into his
studies obviously all his grades like
improved everything like that because he
started to get scared he's like well
[ __ ] i have to
make a living he didn't have like a
family to fall back on because his
family was
poor so uh so yeah that god had that lit
of fire under his ass
now apparently he had been contemplating
maybe going into
like being a minister something like
that like his dad was and i guess his
dad thought that he was going to go into
that line of work too although he wasn't
like
super into the idea i guess he had a lot
of other relations that were also
clergyman
i think that his main thing he wanted to
um study archaeology i think was like
his first thing
or zoology he wanted zoology or
archaeology or something like that
but the problem was that his family was
poor and the only university that they
could afford to send him to
was the one uh you know in town in basil
in switzerland and they offered neither
zoology nor
archaeology so carl was just kind of
like well [ __ ]
um how about i will
study psychiatry and medicine because
those were available at that university
so that and he would be able to get a
grant so his family wouldn't have to put
up a whole bunch of money which they
didn't have
so that's what he started doing so 1895
he started studying
medicine at the university of basil
um which actually was very uh
turned out to be really interesting for
him because as i said studying
psychiatry like kind of
it went into like his rational side and
also kind of his
interest in anthropology history that
kind of stuff so it kind of encompassed
everything so he kind of got into it
now 1895 as i said was also the year
that kind of
sigmund freud came onto the scene with
you know one of his
very famous you know first publications
so
this was probably like the best time to
be getting into
that field now about a year after he was
at university his dad
died and the family was left uh pretty
destitute
so other relatives had to kind of like
pitch in and like help him so he could
finish
his studies so
1900 he moves to zurich and he starts
working at this psychiatric hospital
under this dude named
eugen boiler i hope hopefully i'm
pronouncing that right
now boiler uh significantly
was a colleague of sigmund freud
who at this point was already starting
to get kind of famous
for his publications and
so basically around this time
young starts to in 1903 he publishes his
dissertation now his dissertation
interestingly because like i said he was
always interested in
science but he was always also
interested in anthropology in
spirituality religion all that kind of
stuff
so he had gotten real into spiritualism
as a lot of people were at the time
he had a um cousin named helene
pricework who was a medium
and i guess he had been to some of her
seances and he had
started developing like some theories
about
uh you know paranormal activity what was
causing it or whatever
so that was the subject of his
dissertation
uh the dissertation being titled on the
psychology and pathology of so-called
occult phenomena that was
his you know what the paper was called
so here you know here
very early on we see this kind of
his interest in both scientific
rationality and his interest in
spirituality kind of yeah but what's
funny is that during those days there
wasn't a big division between there
really wasn't which you really have to
take into consideration
i mean there was a lot of people that um
you know uh
the spiritism movement was that actually
[ __ ] pretty directly related to
science
uh i mean you're dealing with societies
that
basically were biblical so
of course spiritism and the supernatural
is going to be part of science
you know i mean that's just the way it
is the way it was and i find that i find
that time period
yeah i find that time period like really
really fascinating because
like you said um you know biblical
literalism was still very much a big
thing i mean
you know you have to think like darwin
didn't publish on the origin of species
until 1859
and even then it was like pretty
controversial not in scientific circles
but in within the public
so i kind of feel like a lot of people
were still in the sway of
i said what we would nowadays call
creationism yeah
well the bible said their souls yeah the
bible said that creationism happened
and so science kind of agreed with that
you know
i mean to to disagree with that was
almost kind of like
an anomaly yeah about it you know
yeah when uh when darwin started to say
well
no species differentiated
due to natural selection that was a big
deal
it was a massive deal it was what they
call a paradigm shift
right they're like well you know the
natural [ __ ] world bred things into
being what they are they weren't created
as they are they [ __ ] bred themselves
through the through a pr through the
process of nature
yeah and essentially in an essentially
indifferent process yeah yeah the bible
did not say that right
and most your scientists did not say
that a lot of people [ __ ]
are like what are you talking about
science science was not secular
up until eve to recently i mean
physics which was old [ __ ] isaac
newton okay
was a secularist not only next to me
was a biblical he was not a secularist
okay
in fact isaac newton
was deep deep into [ __ ] um
what do you call it when you're trying
to find a source of alchemy he was an
alchemist
yeah okay so young was into that too
actually yeah
so you know these people believed in
paranormal stuff and
supernatural stuff but it wasn't weird
there wasn't like a big dichotomy like
nowadays it's a big dichotomy between
you know you're a skeptic you're a
rationalist yeah there it
is there wasn't that distinction back
then it was a lot grayer
which kind of should give you kind of a
different light on the works of mary
shelley
and frankenstein okay because uh
she was also in that world she wrote a
story about
somebody that brought a corpse back to
life you know frankenstein
first science fiction story by all
accounts
you know what i mean and uh
today you go yeah that's that you know
bringing of course back to life maybe
something like that might be possible
but that's even weirder back in her day
when you're worried about souls
you know what i mean oh yeah you're like
well where's that soul come from
you brought somebody back to life did
they come back from hell
yeah it was a much bigger consideration
bigger consideration back then than it
would be nowadays yeah nowadays it's
just like well you know
your consciousness is an emergent
property of your brain
working so of course you you gain
consciousness because you were brought
back to life
right but you're a new person that's not
really what that meant
in mary's mary shelley i kind of feel
like they felt like souls were like a
you know a a discreet it was a thing
it was a thing yeah you know what i mean
so it had to
come from somewhere it had to go
somewhere yeah and what what did that do
did that soul have to leave heaven in
order to [ __ ] go into this body
right this was like serious discussions
that they had which like i said i'm not
making fun of them though
they was just that was the normal that
was the normal thinking of the time
scientific thinking of the time where'd
that soul come from right
i mean back then you had people like
weighing
you know people that were dying and like
then weighing them a few minutes later
to see
like what the difference is like how
much does the soul weigh and all this
other kind of stuff
you had all that kind of stuff going on
that was a very serious consideration
that they had
yeah so you know but and i'm like
fascinated by i mean i've always been
fascinated
with you know not so much spiritualism
itself but the whole context surrounding
it and like people that
um you know were into it
and even like you know people that were
ostensibly like scientists and stuff
like that that were into it
and i just find that really really
interesting and like i said that's not
to like [ __ ] on people at all because
i don't like necessarily to
take our modern sensibilities and you
know impose them upon people from the
past because
you know they didn't know the [ __ ] that
we know nowadays
but i just i find it really interesting
how
different lines of thought emerged
i guess which is which is like i said i
i found like the whole process of
researching carl young and freud and
everything like they've been i knew a
little bit about them
before this but i you know reading a
bunch of books about them i'm really
fascinated by the whole context of
their time period and like where they
were coming from
because you have to think nowadays
topics like
you know the collective unconscious or
topics like
word association tests even [ __ ] like
that introversion extroversion stuff
like that
you have to think that you know to us it
seems very like old hat but back then
it was very very modern very very
cutting edge
this was something that you know young
and freud and people like that
came up with back then in the context of
the time being in the late 19th century
when this was not
a thing this was not a thing that a lot
of people in the public
like knew about yeah you know yeah and
don't think that we've conquered it
today either we still don't know we've
never we're never going to come to the
end there's always something else to
learn we can't explain consciousness
nobody really knows what it is is it
inside the brain
is it outside the brain i think it's
outside the brain in a quantum field
or it might be a combination it might be
partly inside partly outside there might
be some kind of you know who knows it's
like
i think the brain has is where memory is
stored
i'm not sure that's exactly where
consciousness is
you know that's just on my personal
experience though
and like uh even
uh some of your uh oh what's his name
[ __ ]
roger pembros penn roseanne penrose he's
kind of skeptical
uh about the brain being the seat of
consciousness
you know i mean as i said i'm not a lot
there
yeah i mean i'm a rationalist i'm a
materialist
um you know i i would imagine that most
of consciousness
you know what you perceive as your
consciousness comes from your brain
but i am perfectly willing to accept
that there might be something
out there there might be some kind of
link with some kind of outside
like i said you know going back to young
it could be like some kind of weird
collective unconscious thing
but there might be some underlying
structure to that there might be some
kind of underlying principle to that
that we just don't understand yet
there isn't a way to know right now
right that's what i'm saying there's no
sense in even really arguing about it
yeah that's what i'm saying i kind of
like believe that
consciousness is very different than
mind
okay yeah who you are your memories
all that stuff is probably in your brain
okay
uh it doesn't that doesn't necessarily
give you this sensation of being
that sensation of being or this is
the sensation of of
presence that you have like i feel like
i'm here
i don't believe it's inside the brain i
think it's
i think it's like what roger pembrous
rose says
it's a some kind of quantum process
going on you know
yeah that's perfectly that's what the
soul would be that's perfectly possible
yeah
and it may not really be uh it may not
really be
uh dependent on the
on the physical presence of a brain
yeah which i'm kind of [ __ ] up and i'm
having a hard time explaining
it but uh when you die
i don't think you lose your point of
view
but based upon my near-death experience
you lose a real
close connection with
the sensation of being who you were you
know what i'm talking about
yeah like when i had a near-death
experience
i didn't feel real connected to tom ross
i remember i remembered him
but it was like it was somebody else
like a role that i had been playing
like a character i had played but that's
not me
who i was was a lot simpler and it was
more in the here and now
it wasn't dependent on memory i felt
very squirrel-like
like a little creature that could exist
that could
see you know what i mean it was like i
felt more like a point of view
than a person than a person yeah
which you know maybe that's what it is
maybe there's just some kind of
rudimentary
yeah it was real rudimentary um you know
a fragment of you that's kind of out
there like i said
in yongi in terms and the collective
unconscious but
all your memories your actual um
you know experience of yourself as an
individual maybe that
all does reside in your brain but there
is some little bit of you
i felt like i had possessed tom ross
you know i'm talking about and
experienced his life but that wasn't me
what i was was a lot simpler
and it was just like a point of view and
it was free
outside of the time space continuum
and it could go into anything or anyone
and it was kind of like watching a movie
yeah yeah i mean yeah yeah that's what
it more felt like
to me and it was all fun
yeah it was not a serious business
which i i would hope that that's a
liberating message
to you people that it wasn't serious
really
it was all fun and games well i kind of
try like i said as much of a
materialist or whatever as i am it just
does kind
of honestly all i want is that when i'm
dying
it's like as long as i think to myself
hey it's gonna be okay like before i die
then i'm good
yeah that's what it's like it's actually
that simple
okay yeah well then i'm good yeah yeah
i'm not worried about it it doesn't
matter to me if i'm like come back later
that doesn't matter to me um you know
what i'm saying
but uh yeah so as i said so
so the first thing we're so he's already
getting a little bit
into as i said spiritualism and talking
about mediums and
that kind of stuff now 1903 another
significant thing that happens
is that he gets married now the woman
that he married was named emma
rauschenbach now this was uh
interesting for many reasons because
emma came from a
very very wealthy family uh her
family had been involved they had a lot
of businesses but probably their most
significant one sold like luxury watches
so they had like [ __ ]
boku money so hold on one second
[ __ ] michael shay for [ __ ] he had
he brought up a good thing
it's like the vulcan catra yeah
yeah it's like the katra that's what it
is
yeah victor said all i want when i die
is for the rest of the world to die with
me
damn that's all right they don't
they don't want to go it's all right
yeah i'm i'm all right with it
i'm i've i've achieved it i've achieved
a state of zen about it mark was
asking me about it and they're talking
about this on the screen like
yeah quantum scoring somebody yeah it's
like it's
yeah it's like a being a squirrel
chicatra yeah
yeah that makes that kind of make sense
yeah
you know but yeah so this woman he
married
um apparently here's the weird thing
apparently what happened was that he had
seen her somewhere or so he claimed
later because he's a big um
carl young was a big advocate of uh
synchronicity um it was one of the big
things that he came up with it's like
you know [ __ ] that and
and like predestination not necessarily
predestination but like
you know there were no such thing as
coincidences he was kind of into that
so apparently he saw this girl first
when she was
14 maybe i don't think they didn't get
married till later it's fine
but um he saw her and he was like yeah
that's the girl i'm gonna marry
and he was in his 20s at the time and he
did end up marrying her later on
now this as i said this was significant
because her family
was super super wealthy which meant
uh because of his broke ass that he
didn't have to worry about
not having money anymore because now he
was like funded
because he was pitching yeah he was
married to this like really really
wealthy
family and married into this wealthy
family um but it also turned out that
his wife emma was also pretty kick-ass
like in her own right she wasn't like
super educated as a lot of women at the
time were not however
when she started getting into his
theories and reading his stuff she got
really really into it
and actually she ended up being i
believe his uh
you know his assistant when he went to
work at a mental hospital later
and um you know so she was very much
instrumental in
helping him you know develop his
theories and write about his stuff and
everything so you know
now one thing i will note is that
i've seen this put a couple of different
ways in modern parlance we could
probably say
that their marriage was an open marriage
i'm not really sure
if she was super on board with this
but it's not like women had a lot of say
in the matter back then
um carl young not gonna lie
was by all accounts bit of a pronoun
um he was kind of like he'd see
a hot lady and he'd be like yep i'm
gonna get that
and he wasn't real ethical about whether
they were
they had come to him for analysis or
whatever
um he actually did get into some
relationships with women that
he was um you know analyzing and whatnot
because like i said you know psychiatry
was kind of a new field back then
so maybe ethics wasn't a consideration
but he was uh banging some chicks
allegedly
uh you know on the thing now apparently
she did his wife didn't know about it
i don't think she was entirely happy
about it
but i guess they kind of later came to
some understanding
because they did actually remain married
until she died and
she didn't die until 1955 um
but like i said i don't think she was
super jazzed about it i don't know if
she
got any of her own on the side i hope
she did
but uh because apparently he had a whole
bunch on the side so hopefully
she took up her end of that bargain but
um
but i'm not real sure but like i said he
was uh you have to think if you've seen
pictures of him
he was uh not you know not a lot a bad
looking dude
for the time uh he was real tall he was
apparently super super charismatic
really magnetic
um and uh ladies loved him
so he was really not shy about taking
women up on that [ __ ]
whether he was married or not and um you
know so
there was that whole thing but like i
said he did remain married to his wife
until
her death in 1955 and she was actually
instrumental in
helping him a great deal in his work and
i guess
she either just put up with it or
was having her own fun on the side i
don't really know nobody knows
but that's i'm that's all i'm going to
say about that
now so 1905
um carl young gets appointed to the
permanent uh senior doctor at the
hospital
and you know also became a lecturer
lecturer at zurich
university now
so let's talk a little bit about this
relationship
between young and freud because i feel
like this was a massive
influence not only on both parties
involved but also kind of on the history
of
psychology psychiatry in general
so what ends up happening there was
about a 20-year age gap
between the two men so as i said freud
was already
fairly famous by the time young came on
the scene
now what ends up happening is that
one of um a friend of young's
knew freud and when young
published his first book he actually
tried to send a copy to freud but freud
had already purchased it because here's
the thing
i feel like freud as i mentioned earlier
he kind of you know he came up with the
whole thing about psychoanalysis
and his whole thing was kind of like
every neurosis
can and you know this might be a
simplification this is a simplification
but he was kind of like well every
neurosis can be tied back to some
sexual thing like in someone's childhood
right in their upbringing edible complex
all that kind of stuff
so i kind of feel like he thought
everything could be tied back to that
and even from a very very early stage
a lot of his colleagues were already
kind of starting to be like man don't
you think that's a little narrow or
don't you think
that you know not everything can be tied
back to that you're too fixated on it
so he was getting blow back even back
then
you know it's a victorian thing it is to
blame everything on [ __ ]
sex sure and [ __ ] toilet training
that's really what he was all about sex
and toilet training
and i don't really think that's [ __ ]
yeah everything was like genitally
focused
yeah and i feel like that might be more
you know i i don't want to cast
aspersions on the dude but
it does seem like maybe that's more he's
projecting
yeah that might be more of like a
projection of something that he was
going through but you know most people
aren't that fixated on this [ __ ]
well well the thing about it is that
anytime you're trying to tie
something as complex as human behavior
back to one single factor
i feel like you're doomed to failure
yeah because
humans are very complicated creatures
and you know whatever you have going on
in your life whatever negative [ __ ]
that you have going on i don't think
that there's ever it's there it's never
just like a one-to-one
thing never it's always an interaction
of [ __ ] you have going on in your brain
[ __ ] you have going on in your
family [ __ ] you have the [ __ ] that's
going on like
in the wider world there's just all kind
of
so many different things like
interacting to a point where
you can't really separate what the exact
cause is
you know what i'm saying so i feel like
any time you're trying to be like
oh well you know you have this
particular neurosis because
your mom didn't breastfeed you enough
yeah i mean anytime you're trying to
like me
that's very reductive right and i feel
like even at the time
other people were getting on freud's
case about that and even young
as much as he admired freud um
i think even he got to a point where the
well this is too limiting and he had to
come
and which i think led to the rift
between the two of them which did happen
later on like they worked together for
about six years
when you think about it though
because i can remember my reaction to
this
[ __ ] when i first heard about it well
you
are having this problem because back
when you were a baby your mama said this
and this
it almost kind of like sounded like
maybe it'd be plausible
because it was so meticulous well
you're talking about easy like it's very
easy when you're like
yeah maybe that man yeah but that's not
the way
life is you know i mean it's just that's
just not how life
is well yeah he's he's he was he's
overdoing it
well like i said and i can see why life
is too
long yeah there's too much time involved
in it
you know what i mean to trace your
problem back
to a single one thing thing you know
what i mean that took
two seconds that's not the way life is
that's what i mean and i think i feel
like we've hit on this a little bit when
we talk about serial killers and we talk
about their upbringing and blah blah
blah we talk about nature nurture all
that kind of stuff
i just feel like the reason that no one
has come to um
kind of a specific [ __ ] answer to all
this is because there isn't one it's
just it's too
complex to be prized apart
humans are not digital that's what i
mean it's not a thing where it's like
you know hey like your mom [ __ ] up
your toilet training or she looked at
your genitals funny or something like
that one time
and subsequently you're like you became
a kleptomaniac or whatever it doesn't
work that way it doesn't work like that
um you know everyone's life is just uh
this huge panoply of a million
different uh influences a million
different
and like i said it's it's [ __ ] you think
it's just the outside world it's your
cultural context it's your family it's
everything yeah your mom
looked at your junk that's why you're
[ __ ] up okay
that's a that's like a [ __ ] really
good
[ __ ] pat answer to your problems all
right
but when you really look at it that's
the same kind of [ __ ] l ron hubbard was
telling people
that's why i mean like i understand it's
life is not that [ __ ] simple and
that's the thing and i understand
humans are very yeah they really
want there to be an easy answer to
everything
it's like look i can take this pill and
i'll lose weight or i'll buy this
particular piece of exercise equipment
and i'll lose weight
you know what i mean yeah people want
easy solutions to their problems
but i hate to tell you there isn't
there just isn't that but it's very
attractive to people to want that though
yeah
the truth is is that you're [ __ ] up
because it was a long
time of things [ __ ] you up and you
reacted in a [ __ ] up way
so you are [ __ ] up that's that's the
truth
of it that's the truth of the matter you
gotta unfuck yourself
the silver lining in that is that
everyone is [ __ ] up
to a certain extent we're all [ __ ] up
you better it's okay no that's what i'm
saying it's a
you know it i know it it might not be
that comforting for people but it's like
look everyone's [ __ ] up to a certain
degree
everybody we're all humans no one's
perfect
everyone's got bad [ __ ] going on
everybody just have fun
just yeah just you can't worry about it
too much you can't
you know i'm just saying yeah
i know it sucks everything sucks just
don't worry about it you know
it'll be all right listen it'll be all
right
and you don't live that long even if it
isn't going to be all right you don't
live that long anyway
well that's good you know what you know
what's weird it's like this is
this is this is something that i know
this is like
strange or maybe this is just me but in
sometimes
like if i get real upset about something
this actually makes me feel better i
always
i always feel like if some if i if
something went wrong and
i feel really bad about it i always
think to myself
okay in the grand scheme of the universe
as in going back to like the [ __ ]
time when the asteroid hit the earth and
like wiped out all the dinosaurs and
[ __ ] like that
in 50 years will anyone give a [ __ ]
about that
will anyone remember me will anyone and
you know what it's like
that's it's kind of comforting because
you kind of think
it seems like a big deal right now it's
like oh my god it's the end of the world
blah blah blah but it's like if you put
things in context if you put things in
perspective like that
it's like look no one's going to care no
one's going to remember
actually even a year from now no one
will remember
and it's fine it blows my mind
it blows my [ __ ] mind i'm 51 years
old
i feel young as [ __ ] 20 years
goes by like nothing it goes by quickly
all right 20 years i'll be 71 years old
when i was growing up that was an old
[ __ ] man that was a real old man
i i can't believe it i can't believe it
and i know that you a lot of you are the
same age as me out there
well i think that of like everybody goes
through that because
nobody can believe yeah everybody has
yeah well and everybody has this weird
conception of themselves
as they're going to be the exception to
the rule no
no no i feel like everybody feels like
that yeah
everybody feels like that right you
weren't made to live that long and maybe
that's a good thing
it's like what i'm getting old and
decrepit what the this wasn't supposed
to happen to me
yeah yeah it happens to everybody though
yeah but i feel like everybody goes
through that
you know what i mean so if you can like
remove yourself
this is my spock [ __ ] talking again yeah
you need to remove yourself from that
mindset and look at that mindset from
outside of yourself
now i will tell you this this is true
because of technology and just the way
the [ __ ] world is going
51 is not what 51 was back in 1920.
well yeah it's not the same it's not the
[ __ ] i mean i will say that
there are i did hear some people
saying that the people that are alive
today could live to be about 120 years
old and that they
that they'll live [ __ ] basically a
quality of life
of what they would have you know i mean
when they were [ __ ]
i was 60 year old today i mean maybe
that's true i don't i don't [ __ ] know
well there's no way we'll see when we
get there
um you're not really
either there is nothing in [ __ ]
science
that says that that you have to age
it's just something that happens it's
more like an error
it's an error in your replication of
your dna
so as technology [ __ ] gets better
you might well we're definitely living
longer everything that is medical
is a it's a life extension
and people of our age i feel like look a
lot younger now than they
did 20 or 30 years ago the stress on
people a long time ago
or let's say the stress
on say my dad was a lot more
a lot more than it is on me i think i
mean he aged at a lot faster rate
and then i look at my grandparents and
uh
they lived into their 70s or 80s but
they were [ __ ] up even in their 40s
yeah you know what i mean it's like it
that's why
that's why i don't really get like
people pissing and moaning about oh
that's the end of the world nowadays
it's like oh my god do you know how much
like [ __ ]
easier it is nowadays than it was back
then holy crap
i'm very aware of how much easier it is
nowadays yeah
so i'm just like not going to worry
about it see what happens i'm taking
advantage
oh but a lot of little things that are
cheap today
were super expensive back then so it has
an impact
like for instance i have a machine
that takes my blood pressure okay
it'll tell me what my blood pressure is
yeah nothing didn't cost anything
but in the time of my grandfather that
machine would have been
thousands of dollars which is funny
because now you can walk into any cvs
and
get your blood pressure for free right
and the little or publix has one too
and you can also get little machines
that'll test your blood pressure or your
blood sugar level
and that was that was unheard of in my
grandfather's time
so look at all the [ __ ] you can do with
[ __ ] apps on your cell phone now
yeah yeah come on so it is changing
everything is so easy yeah and i don't
think that's bad i think i don't think
we should complain about that oh
everything's too easy now good
good i don't think [ __ ] should be hard
especially [ __ ] like that
i mean come on if we can make [ __ ]
easier for people like that
then we should yeah absolutely but
people also have to understand that in
order to [ __ ] really reap the
benefits of this kind of [ __ ] diet
exercise
you can't just sit around eating
unlimited amounts of food
well i've never been able to [ __ ]
kill you yeah
but um and
that advice that i'm giving you about
[ __ ] diet and exercise that goes all
the way back to the [ __ ] greek age
you realize that you had [ __ ]
um archimedes with saying [ __ ] like that
that was [ __ ] what 2 000 years ago
well at least
2000 archimedes was saying exercise
eat well and you'll live a long time
you know but uh just goes to show they
weren't so dumb back then yeah they
weren't done
well and some of this some [ __ ] is just
you know our biology is the same as
people back then so
they figured that out you eat too much
you'll get fat and you'll die earlier
yeah so you know that's how [ __ ] goes
so all right so can we honestly it's the
only difference between a decade or so
i mean it's not like you can save
yourself a [ __ ] thousand years of
lifespan
well yeah i mean you're still gonna die
but the thing about it is that
you might get an extra 10 years and you
have to think too
that what it's not just like the length
of time it's like the quality the
quality of it
i mean you don't want to live like 20
years on a [ __ ] ventilator obviously
right or you know or not being able to
walk or just like laying in bed like one
of those like [ __ ]
thousand pounds yeah there is like a lot
of new [ __ ] that's been happening of
course you know a [ __ ]
uh what's being learned in uh fitness
and like you guys know that i'm not 100
[ __ ] natural i have [ __ ] around
with sarms and stuff
but if you look at what was happening in
the 70s the guy's like arnold and [ __ ]
you find out that
things like anabolic steroids can
[ __ ] kill you early yeah you look
great when you're young but by the time
you're [ __ ]
70 or 80 you're [ __ ] shot
don't [ __ ] with that stuff you know um
but then you can you can flip that
around
backwards and say well you had guys like
um
uh [ __ ] jacqueline lane who didn't
mess with it
didn't mess with anabolic steroids until
they were already old
and they lived into their 90s so
there are some things that you can do
with these drugs that are out there you
know
just saying and as i said [ __ ] when
you're young
right right and to an extent it's like i
would never
advocate depending too much on any one
thing
but it's just kind of like anything
whether we're talking about technology
or whether we're talking about you know
biological or you know any kind of like
you know
enhancement drugs or anything like that
yeah i just kind of feel like
if that is gonna be a benefit to you if
you're not abusing it
then by all means you should take
advantage
if you think that it's going to have an
advantage for you personally
if you don't want to do it then don't
yeah
from what i've been seeing you know as a
guy 51 years old
my age live a fit and healthy life for
as long as you can
when you start getting into your [ __ ]
50s if you have to mess with those
anabolics and all kinds of weird [ __ ]
drugs if you i think that that will
extend your life there's [ __ ]
uh there's some evidence of that
some guys have lived a long time but you
don't want to take that early
it's yeah i can't end yeah i kind of
feel like
like you said i i feel like people that
took
steroids until like that when they were
younger it [ __ ] them up
yeah i feel like if you're gonna do that
wait till you're already old and then
you have
less to risk yeah and
because you'll see more you'll see more
advantage
yeah it seemed like they had like bumped
themselves up
to be at a certain [ __ ] hormonal
level for longer
yeah they died in their 90s but what's
wrong with that
i mean here that's longer than a lot of
people right
and a guy like [ __ ] jack jack was
[ __ ] in great shape
in his late 80s you gotta be like yeah
he looked good
he was strong his whole life so
you're going to die anyway i mean at
this point i'm kind of like
ambivalent about it yeah i'm ambivalent
about
what age i diet yeah i just i don't
really want to
i just i don't really want to suffer i
don't want to be
to a point where it's just like i just
feel like crap all the time
yeah and i just feel like i'm going on
for the sake of going on i just
i think that's pointless but
if i was able to somehow without having
to like [ __ ]
kill myself you know ironically
um you know to live longer
if i'm still feeling good then [ __ ] i'll
just like keep on trucking
everybody's talking about what we're
talking about right right you know yeah
well i'm just saying we're talking about
like some
you know [ __ ] [ __ ] here so all right
jenny are you shooting tom up with roids
no i'm not on steroids
he's on steroids yeah it's they're kind
of like
they're not steroids they're right i did
take some sarms
yeah but which are what explain that to
people
sarms are um selective androgen receptor
modulators
they have a steroidal effect
but they're not they're not steroids
here because they explain that yeah
they make your system think that maybe
you took something that was steroidal
but
it's not it's just it's just activating
the [ __ ] receptor
um they're
they're not illegal they are legal but
they're
um uh they're not for human consumption
that's what they say it's a it's a
research chemical
um now some people would say well would
you take steroids
yeah [ __ ] right um i would
but it's not really time in in my um
in the way i'm thinking about it
you should take steroids in your final
decades
you know what i mean um
steroidal compounds allow you to [ __ ]
build muscle
uh and what they are is they're kind of
like a uh
they're a hor they're very much kind of
like uh like a fake testosterone
as you get older your [ __ ] normal
uh your normal [ __ ] testosterone
production
starts to kind of wane
so taking some kind of a [ __ ]
hormone can can help keep you
in good health that's a good way to put
it i wouldn't probably take steroids
off the bat i would probably do more
like what's called
hrt which is [ __ ] like hormone
replacement therapy that probably the
first
the first thing i would do a lot of guys
are thinking steroids are trying to get
bigger than they can possibly get
um in order to [ __ ] win these
[ __ ] bodybuilding competitions
you don't really need that all right
i'm kind of [ __ ] loaded
you don't really need that but what
could help you
actually live longer would be hormone
replacement therapy
it doesn't matter if you're a man or a
woman
there are some women out there taking
[ __ ] testosterone
slight amounts of it and [ __ ] they
look great
you just have to [ __ ] know what it is
you're doing you gotta
research and see what other people are
doing and
um you know
if i was an older woman maybe i might
want to consider some of these [ __ ]
hormone
replacement therapies was that a hinge
or something oh no
you can actually do [ __ ] real well
now it doesn't just
now it's not just something that you
[ __ ] inject and and you're
and you're ready you know you have to
[ __ ] exercise too
you know it's not something that's just
it's not some it's not a fix in a bottle
it's gonna require lifestyle changes
diet and exercise you know but that kind
of goes back to what i was saying
earlier where
humans very much want there to be an
easy solution
there is never an easy step but there's
not there there's never anything and you
don't want an easy solution i like hard
solutions
like jenny knows i [ __ ] work out
[ __ ] several times a week
[ __ ] and [ __ ] lifting weights and
[ __ ]
it's the challenge of it
yeah you can't just i mean as much as i
would like
uh you know there to be a pill that
fixes everything so that's that's not
how things go
things are too complicated for that yeah
and that's not how
that's not how metabolism and that's not
how metabolism works that's not how
biology works
you know what i mean your biological
system is like a fire
you have to add fuel to it and you have
to keep the flames going
and it's a it's a metabolism is about
growth
okay growth growth all right
and death is the antithesis of growth
you're not growing you're shrinking
that's what death is
a mummy yeah
and you know you're you're only going to
be able to grow up
to a certain point but you can fight it
you can fight it
yeah i mean you can't just like let
[ __ ] life stomp all over you but
there's only
so much you can do i mean obviously
death is going to come get you in the
end
but you can make it hard for death
when i was working in [ __ ] wellesley
massachusetts
as a salesman i once went into a house
where i met a woman who was in her 80s
and she was beautiful absolutely
beautiful she looked
great when i saw her her
just her face the aura around her
her figure and
she was a an ice skater an olympic
skater
when she was young and she stayed very
active and she showed me pictures of
herself when she was in her [ __ ] 20s
and everything and she looked
she looked like [ __ ] um barbara eden
really
what she looked like
and from that i saw that
old age isn't it doesn't necessarily
isn't necessarily like a sentence of
like a death sentence you know what i
mean
yeah like being fat and ugly yeah it
doesn't necessarily mean now you know
she i know she's dead by now this is a
long time ago
but she was just a um
a very active woman who
worked out [ __ ] you know she was
still going to the gym
and she was in her 80s and she looked
great so
from that that was the first time i
i said i said man people we need to take
a picture you let people know that this
is possible she's like
well i just work out and you know i
still ice skate
and
you control more of your [ __ ]
physiology than you
than than you know you do you know
you do a lot of has to do with the mind
the mind and the body are
closely linked and if you can
[ __ ] bump yourself up with [ __ ]
steroidal compounds